gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 y pregunto a qué se debe el
éxito de este proceso de inmunización
masiva en israel y que reveló
exactamente el estudio de facer
hola que tal como están
bueno acá vamos que el éxito s viene a
hacer que la
el primer ministro de israel cuando
empezó la pandemia ella apostó con las
vacunas de pfizer y de modernas pero más
con la de facer y se comprometió en
adquirir estas vacunas ya desde el
principio al principio cuando empezó la
pandemia y llegamos a hacer un acuerdo
muy importante con facer e israel que
ésta es un país relativamente pequeño y
muy bien organizado tiene 9 millones de
habitantes y ya en el término de dos
meses más o menos ella ha vacunado
prácticamente al 50 por ciento de la
población sea hemos recibido ya unas
seis millones de dosis en más de seis
millones de dosis hay más de cuatro
millones 250 mil personas vacunadas con
la primera dosis y casi tres millones de
personas con la segunda dosis o sea que
el sistema
e israelí es el sistema que está muy
bien organizado con sistemas de
administradores sociales que están que
ocurren un 100 por ciento de la
población es un sistema social que su
sistema gratis que lo tiene toda la
población y eso permitió a extraer al
sistema de salud poder distribuir las
vacunas de forma muy precisa y muy
sistemática a toda la población en tener
los resultados al día y al minuto doctor
de lo que está uno en todo el país
doctor y le pregunta entonces cuál ha
sido su experiencia durante este proceso
de vacunación tengo entendido que usted
ya se vacunó
la experiencia es muy buena lo estamos
viendo que prácticamente no hay enfermos
que nuevos que han pasado las se han
vacunado prácticamente un 0.4 por ciento
de los de la gente que se ha vacunado se
ha infectado en realidad prácticamente
nadie que de los que se ha vacunado yo
recibí las dos dosis en las tres semanas
de diferencia la respuesta a las de la
segunda dosis estuvo un par de días un
poco como afiebrado un poquito con con
debilidad como una gripe normal un par
de días pero por supuesto que vale vale
el hecho de estar vacunado y poder
seguir atendiendo a la gente y debido a
este éxito el gobierno mañana va a
relajar estas medidas de confinamiento
doctor le pregunto si esto entonces no
puede suponer un retroceso en lograr la
inmunidad de rebaño en ese territorio
bueno evidentemente la inmunidad de baño
va a ser muy difícil cuando israel tiene
un gran porcentaje de niños de medio 16
años que personas un 30% de la población
o sea que vamos a poder tener máximo tal
vez un 70% la gente vacunada por ahora
pero igualmente es complicado porque
estamos tratando de abrir el comercio en
forma muy medida y por supuesto que la
gente que se va no recibe a la semana
por eso ya recibir por ejemplo el
certificado de vacunación lo que se
llama el pasaporte verde que nos va a
permitir en poder entrar eso como decías
ahora los por ejemplo a los shop en los
negocios que van a tener el permiso
el certificado verde como se le dice
lara entonces va a poder entrar
solamente gente que tenga ese pasaporte
verde porque aparte de todas las medidas
de distanciamiento y higiénicas por
supuesto